[Music]
welcome back to the amazing episode of
of Z
record we have the great and
G
Nick go ahead Wonder we are going to
start the show and we have a special
guest in silent mic I say that's bad in
silent
mic I think he's kind of German I'm
straighten I feel like I'm in glorious
bastards dude you guys are amazing act
amazing aren't you part German in oh
never mind he's Italian like gorami
gorami I'm German according to your wife
but like yeah you look German she said
thanks but like I'm also Irish too but
she's original white I feel like that's
all the same it is that's not nice no it
is it's it is it is you have to me bro
if you're like right there England
German Irish same same yeah you guys are
Anglo yeah Ang yeah you're Aryan no I'm
just kidding aran's different so um
here's a really fun one I'm excited for
this this is a great promp what is a
story you always fall back on one you've
told so many times that you nearly have
it
memorized a classic your story I think
we tell so many of the same stories on
news all the [__] time that we don't
even remember that we do until people go
you said that [__] already dude anytime
I say a story I feel like I'm saying
piss yeah yeah let's get
pissed they get pissed story get pissed
all right one time I
uh okay this is a good one I was picking
up Tiff from work she worked at like
Loft in Oldtown somewhere right I just
came back from playing basketball
running games all night right and I'm
[__] thirsty I couldn't find my water
bottle and I was in the back seat of my
my car and I'm waiting outside waiting
for tip to come out I found my gallon
jug and it was like a clear Arrowhead
one and I was just grabbed it started
drinking it and right when I drank it I
felt like something was wrong was
something terrible in the water my
cheeks filled
up and I I spit it back into the bottle
and then I put it up to the
light and it was yellow they're
cigarettes pee it's pee Joe it's pee PE
I'm talking about cigarettes you're in
Gatorade in the arrowhead bottle that's
weird brosia bro
and at the moment is it is it lighter
fluid it's orange
juice is Arnold Palmer Brain get there
you never seen I hate Arnold Arnold
Palmer dude I can't even say it right
donate your brain to science you're a
moner you never seen someone Ash their
cigarette inside of a water bottle the
whole thing turns yellow it does
happen that's not the goto thing PE
that's not the go-to thing but that's
just funnier than saying PE cuz I know
the story already I hold it up to the
light and I see that it's [__]
urine and I just start spitting oh dude
it tasted so [__] terrible and just
recently I've been able to tell the
story without like having to be like
like driving cuz usually my eyes start
watering as I tell the story and I'm
spitting outside the car and then I
realized that my dad has this really
cool habit this really cool thing where
he likes to pee in bottles even the big
big ones dude bigger the better right
yeah big you drank you golden showered
from your dad my father dude my own
[__] does that mean he dumped out the
water just to pee in it or did he add to
it was it diluted no he yeah it was
probably diluted he told us this story
you guys don't remember I remember
that's not the point I remember this is
a story talking video and some Joe's the
commenter right
now call this a Story Don't You Remember
story dude so I started spinning out and
I'm just sick to my [__] stomach dude
it was awful it tasted so bad and my dad
dad doesn't drink a lot of water he
drinks a lot of coffee oh [__] he got
the orange pee just a lot of [__]
it's just bad it's just just not that
it's not it's kind of worse that it's
your dad's piss yeah dude way worse what
the [__] my dad's dick was on the
[__] spout and I put my mouth on it
dude see we get new details when we
retell it and and then I'm just sick to
my stomach Tiff comes in the car she's
like hey babe Tres to give me kiss and
I'm like don't [__] kiss me I'm
freaking the [__] out the pain kissing
his dad's dick but if I'm you're [__]
suffering n dude I couldn't did you
drink any of it or did you no I spit it
back out as soon as you tasted it oh
dude it was so bad what it taste like oh
man it just ammonia it tasted like
rancid like I don't know how to explain
it was it was nothing like I I've never
tasted anything like it to this day I
still have't would you if you
were my piss on my face no no would you
drink your own PE cuz you know how some
MMA fighters were doing that their PE
therapy yeah but like that can't be good
no it's stupid I'm doing that 127 Hours
level I'm doing [__] survival if I'm
be grills yeah I'll drink my own piss
survival you do a lot of things for
survival well you just ask if there's a
tap within like I if I can walk five
steps to a tap I think I'll probably
drink water they don't do it for
survival they do it for training yeah
which makes no sense okay well then to
answer your question no I confronted my
dad about this and I called him I was
like Dad you when you pee in the bottle
you have to throw this [__] out I just
drank out of the [__] bottle and he's
like well you should have [__] you
should have looked at it and I was like
look I get it but at the same time I was
like you have to take some blame too you
if you pee in a bottle you can't just
leave it he didn't laugh oh he was
laughing I would laugh I was going to
say if he didn't laugh he's a sociopath
everybody was [__] busting up dude
okay everybody was bust my issue is if
I'm that thirsty I don't think I would
have spit it out like not that I would
taste it and want it not that I would
taste it and want it but I drink so fast
you're not even thinking yeah it's going
straight down before it like hits the
Flav I'll I'll say this yeah no no I'll
say it is there was no [__] way dude
no you know what I mean like I feel like
there's a second it goes down your
throat before it hits the flavonoid are
you is he even a real Drinker is my
thing is Right tequila or whatever you
put down the hatch and then it like you
it goes half down before you taste it
because as soon as it hits your lips
yeah I guess it was warm it was probably
warm would prob smell a little bit too
yeah the smell probably and and this is
why I started wearing no strips cuz I'm
my mouth breather I can't smell very
well you know what I mean well if you
were Kevin Cosner Kevin cner and he
purifies his piss to drink would you
drink it too opening scene of Water
World ises the context yep never even
seen Water World how good's the text why
I said that how good is the
technology I don't know dude it looks
like I it looks like he just peed in an
hourglass and then I don't drink my piss
and I don't eat my poo Bill Gates Bill
hey Water World Bill Gates drinks his
own [__] how no you ever seen this video
no drinks his own [__] so Bill Gates is
that why he got pied in the face Bill
Gates um he he's part of like this water
curing system thing and so like they had
him like piss and [__] and some stuff
and then he was like drinking it how do
to prove it filters how do we really
know and [__] it's probably like the
vaccine the game saline or some [__] n
that [__] went into a cocka machine and
then the other side there was a Kirkland
water bottle waiting and then he just
went like o look at how purified it is
you're probably right yep [__] I what
a scam hey thank you for sharing again
though that was an amazing story it's a
great story even though I heard it for
like the fourth time thank you so much
yeah thanks a lot for that dude I've
already heard the story sorry sorry
sorry yeah I hate this
video what a prompt what a prompt it's
just a fun it's just a fun story it's a
good story this will be an alltime video
no no doubt I could wrap it up I got um
very very classic story of the literally
first moment I met Mike song Have I Told
this story yeah is it when you're in a
dance circle it is when I'm in a dance
circle tell it again thank you for
remember do you remember nope forg
exactly I remember me and I don't pay
attention when you talk I listen I
listen to when you talk bro I don't but
then when Nick is I'm all yours the
crazy thing is I try to pay attention
when you talking I still don't get it
yeah I know all right so uh we're at
we're incoming freshman going to UCI
right and then so there's this thing
called spop student parent orientation
program it's not like the fiscal year
started yet it's just you go to an
orientation where you know people teach
you about [__] school life and [__]
and then to make it orientation Nick
question Nick shout out that's a good
Nick question I'm just freshman or is it
like incoming Juniors as well freshman
do you have a picture of the lanyard uh
no I don't but that's also question um
we're going to how big is the map campus
it's pretty big actually 22,000 ft for
just like after lunch and what did you
eat for lunch yeah do they provide lunch
or I hope it wasn't Pizza cuz I get TI
this all day please don't get me going
today's video is brought to you by Lumi
what is Lumi well for all of you smelly
people out there who are also very
organic and you don't want to fill your
bodies up with dangerous chemicals and
you go you know what I'd rather be
natural this this is exactly for people
like us it is a wonderful deodorant
designed by a OBGYN which is a [__]
doctor this is made for the most stest
stest of smells but it's super safe too
because you got to make sure that the
[__] stays fresh and unharmed that's
right it keeps it pH balanc and that's
not all it's made for the whole entire
body it says for pits privates and
Beyond you could be creative with it the
other day I put it on my shoulder
because when people smell me I think
that this is the first area of attack
right here so this Christmas if you
don't want to be all embarrassed because
you're going to a family gathering and
everyone's like man don't bring Joel
over dude he stinks and this time you
want to smell in fresh and delicious
like tangerine
m i could just smell this all day smells
like delicious soap then get yourself a
Lumi starter pack it comes with the
solid Stick deodorant cream tube
deodorant lavender two free products of
your choice this one I got the wipes
because this is for me on the go this is
the body wash so I could scrub my balls
and best of all free shipping so as a
special offer to you guys new customers
get $5 off a Lumi starter pack with our
special code and for a limited time
returning customers can get $5 off their
next purchase of over
$30 or more too use code
OTR lumid deodorant.com that's code OTR
and if you don't know how to spell Lumi
deodorant it's l u n m e d e
o l u m e d e o d o r a n
t.com never put me in a spelling B thank
you Lumi for making this holiday season
smell a whole lot better now with this I
can have family again my lunch it's at
the cafeteria it's called Brandy Wine
actually cuz Lord of the Rings theme is
Middle Earth for the residents of one
section of incoming
freshman yeah I lived in [__]
Whispering Woods anyway i' probably be
moror dog that would be sick that I
don't think they were trying to
perpetuate evil but other than that well
Evil's dependent on the perspective yeah
that's a very slithering thing to say
cross world deck okay that being said um
both oo this is getting good people
going to beat me up after this video
Yeah well it's cuz you're a
Hufflepuff of [__] I know the hell that
is
squd right so uh so there's this um they
end up throwing this dance uh on the
last night are you a dancer at time uh I
no that's the funny thing uh I thought I
could dance whereas Mike song he [__]
can dance and he's like ripping [__] up
right but the point is there's a giant
Circle not a lot of people are [__]
going in the circle it's like yeah it's
a little bit awkward but I still enjoyed
it I think it was like [__] exhibit
get your walk on you know at that age
you know even though you're
AGC walking a little bit I jump in this
this Cipher if you will and next thing
you know I get a [__] tap on my
shoulder I turn this angry Korean
looking dude just [__] going off on
me I'm not skillful enough to actually
understand what's happening but I am
aware enough to know that if I'm getting
called out I Won't Back Down doesn't
matter I'm not going to back down so we
start going rounds and in a in a very
very dance lame way it starts getting
really intense right and there's a
moment you
sweating maybe good question cuz that's
that means you're [__] pushing if you
so we're going round for round in a
sense maybe like one and a half at a
time was it Head to Head yeah it was
very head-to-head people were chanting
Head to Head were you sore afterwards it
was so cool dude did Nick cannah pop out
with like a microphone or something uh
he wasn't alive back then yeah and then
from there right there's a moment where
Mike's shoe kind of falls off his footo
now here's the thing
I was that aware of battle culture I
just thought it was like respect to like
maybe go grab it and like give it to him
to show like you know respect but he
which is a way smarter battler and
Dancer than me was like oh this
[__] going to use this as a
prop against right so as I start
reaching down towards the shoe full runs
over and he kicks it out the circle he
kicks his own [__] shoe out of
the circle and I was mind blown cuz I
was like this don't even want to wear a
shoe and that's when when it got so
intense that a staffer had to come in
way split us up going to be a turn into
a fight bro I would have had to move
dude put your shoe put your shoe off
you're him can't see what happen you can
you can so I'm hitting it and then I'm
hitting one of these and then I'm
stealing his [__] and I'm [__] out
dog I'm out dog and he would have beat
me yeah that's the play right the shoe
he for sure would have beat me get your
welcome
get I would have been out
out dog it's pretty good but then
ironically that was literally the first
moment we met we ended up becoming best
friends after were you like that was a
that was a hard battle and he's like I
know yeah you hit him on AOL Messenger I
was probably like yo man that was hard
he was probably like no that was weak
did you ever ask him why did you call me
out out of all the people there cuz he
needed yeah he needed somebody to [__]
on so he could prove his [__] what
about there's 20 other [__] people
when you're introducing yourself to the
[__] the the mass public you need to
you need to start with a very very good
it's like a warm-up bout make a splash
you know what I
mean his introduction you guys Cool Kids
on Campus after that people high-fiving
you in the [__] hallway and [__]
lowkey yeah even though really he just
dunked on me but yeah lowy but they knew
your face yeah yeah I was like
Associated by associ like those are the
guys that danced okay easy mode ready
easy mode so uh I am 19 years old I fall
asleep I fall asleep and like my hand
like [__] falls asleep too and like
we all this happens to all of us but
mine wouldn't wake up and it's like this
this is not a bit it's not a joke this
actually happen it's medical [__] you
right my nerves in my wrist were dead
this happens now no no no this happened
to be 19 and so um this doesn't happen
anymore I don't know why it wouldn't
happen anymore but yeah this didn't
hasn't happened to me since thank God
but yeah my my hand Frozen like this
like I can't use my nerves to lift my
wrist at all so it's like completely
like this this I'm right-handed so now
I'm like holy [__] what the [__] and of
course I'm such a [__] troll and I'm
such a [__] [__] that my parents
are like what are you talking about
Steve of course Your Hand Works shut the
[__] up and like also this looks kind of
funny right like come on so so then he
looks West Hollywood nobody believes me
yeah they're all like haha wayho and
[__] but then I'm like no really I can't
move it and then they're like yeah right
St whatever and I started slap I started
smacking my hand on cabinets and [__]
like that and then and then they're not
believing me they're laughing like you
guys are and then I turned I turned up
the water in the house where to where
the steam is rising I shove my hand into
it and I'm like see I can't [__] even
feel the [__] and my mom runs over and
grabs my she's like Stephen oh my God
what the [__] is going on and then I had
to go to the doctor doctor's like yeah
you have this type of py where like we
don't even know when the yeah type of
paly can't remember what it's called but
the they're like it's it's happened to
people it's happened to people who like
fall asleep on benches outside like the
homeless people and stuff like that he
was like explaining to me and I was like
holy [__] that's when something falls
asleep for too long too long the the
blood didn't go in there for long enough
your nerves are dead and we and nerves
are so tricky we don't know when they'll
regenerate we have no idea and there is
a chance that you'll never be able to
move your hand again I was like what the
[__] are you talking about dude crazy so
then I have to I have to go to physical
therapy and this is the worst part of
the whole entire Endeavor so in physical
therapy I'm there this is like early
I'm there with guys who served in Iraq
got their legs blown off and [__] like
that right and like you're talking to
people and like what happened to you
it's like oh dude [__] I IED and [__]
I was in a jeep serving in the [__]
20 223rd I'm like oh my god dude I fell
asleep watching
Superman and I fell asleep my hand I
fell asleep with my hand watching
Superman 2 Christopher Reeves and and
this guy like really and then what the
[__] really and I'm like yeah yeah and
then um so then the worst part too is
I'm like I have a brain I'm a human
being all this stuff but the nurse is
like is like Stephen can you take the
red ball and put it through the red hole
the red uh uh ball hole and I'm like
yeah of course I can [__] do that she
talking to me like I'm a little kid like
my my wrist is limp I'm not de I'm not
dead I know I have a brain function I
like I don't have like a plate on my
head the [__] are you talking to me like
this for and then I'm like of course I
can and then and then like to show off
I'm like
I'm like oh jeez this really oh and then
she's like yeah it's okay Stephen you
can do it you can do it that's a boy and
[__] yeah it's like that like like you
go from being like why are you talking
to me like this to be like oh I need the
encouragement really helps yeah I need
thank you thank you actually but yeah it
was like that so then you know
thankfully it took like 3 months holy
[__] eventually my and yeah like it was
like weird but eventually my rist start
to come back and then yeah now I know
you're a liar why cuz you can't beat me
at Halo taking 3 months off Dog I'd be
grinding every
dayer I have an elite controller that's
why you're such an idiot I have a
[__] Elite controller SW the parts
out dude I swap the parts out so I can
move my my fingers faster and yes you're
right I cannot move to this day I can't
move this this Dum as fast as this throw
but guess what I don't need it cuz I
have a elite controller I spent $150 on
that [__] he moded up H worry
about it dude an idiot bro kills me hey
were you were you kind of like depressed
during that time like scared that's
[__] crazy [__] dude cuz like I
couldn't get by like you know I finger
blast was my
jam and then I I was like I lost I lost
got so good at that I lost my trick shot
you know you're Ace in the no hook shot
like Kem without the hook shot yeah it's
like I'm [__] it's over right yeah so
yeah scary scary times that is
scary but yeah
than that's the worst part seeing people
who served and like they really went
through some [__] and I'm yeah that
shirt looks really good on you Mike what
is it it's a careful Boy shirt you guys
could go on the link below get it right
now what a
[Laughter]
[Music]
transition